hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today's
question comes from one of my newsletter
readers Diana wrote in asking I'm in the
network marketing business and I want to
know what the most fruit roll fruitful
and rewarding way of getting business
builders into the business is without
having to coerce them or having them
join only to incubate them and then
there's no growth of the business
regards Diana so thank you the question
Diana getting the right people on board
is one of the biggest challenges that
any entrepreneur is going to face in the
network marketing business or just
running a regular business and I think
the biggest challenge you're going to
have to face here is you want to get
people who are really passionate about
the product and want to help people and
not just get warm bodies because you're
looking for people it's one of the
biggest mistakes you can make is getting
the wrong person in for the job if you
have the wrong person in your business
it can be such a time suck and energy
suck they take so much of your emotion
emotional energy and mental energy away
from you and prevents you from be able
to focus on growing your business so you
want to build to build beyond yourself
it's it's you know if you don't build me
on yourself you're always going to be
limited by how much time you have but
you want to make sure you bring it on
the right people and really selective so
it's better to have a smaller core group
of people who are really good at what
they do and really love what they're
doing then to have tons of people who
are mediocre not great and are sopping a
lot of your energy so for you I don't
know what have products you're selling
in the network marketing industry but
let's say it's beauty products for
example what I would try to do is find
people who are really passionate about
beauty products and also really like
helping people and that's going to be
you know a really specific set of people
who would be potential targets for you
but that's good you don't want to go
after anybody and everybody right you
don't want the person who is just in it
to try to make some money we doesn't
really care about beauty products
doesn't really want to help people
they're just trying to you know do a
cash grab that's not going to be your
ideal type of person you want somebody
who really has a passion for your
products and really likes helping people
and if
can really focus your attention finding
those people it may be a lot fewer
immediately bring in a couple people a
year instead of 100 people a year but
those couple people would be really
focused on helping you grow your
business and the right type of people to
bring on board so it's also a lot more
fun you know if you're working with
people who love what they're doing and
they're helping your customers and your
customers are you know getting great
results as well then it's a lot more fun
you've seen the value that you're adding
the people's lives and that's really
what being an entrepreneur is all about
the second thing I just quickly advise
you to do once you found those right
people you want to make sure that you
train them well and that you make it as
easy as possible for them to start
making money you want to set them up for
success as best you can so really make
sure you're spending the time with them
coaching them guiding them through the
process making it easy for them you'd be
give them a few leads go with the Mon
sales calls try to make it as easy as
possible really invest your time again
you're investing more time in fewer
people who think are really you know a
candidates for you instead of a lot of
time invested across you know 100 people
who are all media for candidates so if
they can get set up and feel comfortable
and confident and they're starting to
make money and they're seeing some early
success then it's going to be easier for
them to want to stick around and keep
going and and you basically get in the
past that survival stage is gonna be the
hardest part so hopefully that helps
Diana for those of you guys watching if
you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below it always makes me want
to make more these videos for you guys
and I know you like them and if you have
a thought or comment I love to hear it
below if you want to leave it under the
video I always read those too so thank
you and we'll see you on the next
episode
you
you